[Música]
bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
historia se cumplen 10 años de una de
las revoluciones más estruendosas de la
primavera árabe la revolución egipcia el
25 de enero de 2011 egipto estalló en un
clamor social cientos de miles de
jóvenes salieron a protestar en contra
de 30 años de opresión política régimen
autoritario y brutalidad policial con el
asesinato del presidente anuar el sadat
por radicales islámicos en 1981 su vice
presidente hosni mubarak ascendió al
poder a su mando egipto recorrió cerca
de tres décadas de autoritarismo
corrupción y violencia contra civiles
mubarak lindo su gobierno con una ley de
emergencia o estado de excepción que
amparó a la policía con facultades anti
constitucionales como detenciones
arbitrarias golpizas y electrocuciones
el pueblo egipcio vivió atemorizado de
expresarse libremente su pena de ser
arrestado y torturado
definitivamente tenía una base de apoyo
especialmente cuando comenzó trató de
revertir mucho las políticas de su
predecesor sadat y fue aceptado en ese
momento pero después de 30 años la
arrogancia del poder la corrupción la
falta de responsabilidad porque saben
que te vas a quedar para siempre le hizo
perder toda la aceptación que tuvo
alguna vez
la inspiración para cambiar el sistema
opresor provino de túnez el país del
norte de áfrica donde eclosionó la
primavera árabe esa oleada de revueltas
populares para derrocar a los ya
veteranos y autócratas líderes árabes el
17 de diciembre de 2010 un vendedor
ambulante tunecino se inmoló luego de
que la policía le arrebatara sus
mercancías y lo despojara de sus ahorros
este fue el detonante para que el pueblo
saliera en masa a protestar harto de la
injusticia social y así cayó el
presidente ben alí que llevaba 23 años
en el poder
en egipto el ejemplo tunecino contagio a
cientos de miles de jóvenes que se
trazaron el mismo norte derrocar a hosni
mubarak de manera que el 25 de enero de
2011 diversos grupos sociales
organizaron manifestaciones a través de
las redes sociales entre las que se
destacaron las ocurridas en cuatro
ciudades el cairo alejandría suez e
ismailía la policía respondió con gases
lacrimógenos mientras que los jóvenes
con palos y piedras exigían la renuncia
del presidente
quiero que mubarak se vaya a egipto ya
no después de un día o una semana
debe irse ahora pero con dignidad él es
un símbolo de nuestro país debe irse con
dignidad y la transición pacífica de la
autoridad es el tema más importante en
esta etapa actual
steitz a ese 25 de enero del 2011 se le
conoció como el día de la ira y el
epicentro ocurrió en la icónica plaza
tahrir de el cairo donde se reunieron 15
mil manifestantes entretanto el gobierno
de mubarak buscó censurar a los medios
de comunicación suspender los servicios
de telefonía móvil así como bloquear a
escala nacional el internet para menguar
la logística de los manifestantes por
medio de facebook y twitter
el gobierno responsabilizó de las
protestas al grupo político islamista de
los hermanos musulmanes en las calles de
el cairo y suez seguían los
enfrentamientos entre policía y
manifestantes y en la icónica plaza
tahrir de
cairo creció bastión de rebeldía un
movimiento de resistencia que incluía a
personalidades de la cultura y el
deporte y que desafío la intimidación de
las fuerzas de seguridad y los toques de
queda allí los jóvenes coreaban al
unísono van libertad y justicia social
su convicción era la de ocupar la
glorieta hasta que mubarak y quiera pero
el presidente no sería buscó calmar los
ánimos al despedir en bloque a todo su
gabinete y reemplazarlo por uno nuevo
pero sus intentos por frenar el
descontento social no surtieron efecto
el primero de febrero de 2011 una nueva
marcha de más de un millón de personas
retumbo en egipto y finalmente el 11 de
febrero de 2011 tras 18 días de
protestas que dejaron cerca de 850
muertos
mubarak entregó el poder
el presidente mohamed hosni mubarak ha
decidido dimitir de su cargo como
presidente de la república y ha dado
poder al consejo supremo de las fuerzas
armadas para gestionar los asuntos del
país buscamos la ayuda de la guía de
dios
factual gusta con la caída de mubarak
las fuerzas armadas tomaron las riendas
del país y prometieron tanto eliminar la
ley de emergencia como llamar a
elecciones presidenciales tras
celebrarse los comicios de mediados de
2012 el candidato de los hermanos
musulmanes mohamed mursi asumió el poder
pero el mandato de bours y no duraría
mucho sus intentos de reformar la
constitución y otorgarles poderes
ilimitados a los militares para arrestar
civiles por la fuerza tanto como el
incremento del sesgo de la religión
islámica en la vida pública de los
egipcios desató un nuevo clamor social
con protestas y manifestaciones el 3 de
julio de 2013 el jefe de la inteligencia
militar el general abdelfatah al cis y
aprovechando la coyuntura ejecutó un
golpe de estado
y destituyó a murcia del mando
el 25 de diciembre del mismo año declaró
oficialmente a los hermanos musulmanes
como organización terrorista
alexis y es actualmente el presidente de
egipto lo sucedido en túnez y egipto se
replicó en la mayoría de los países
árabes del norte de áfrica y de medio
oriente entre el 2010 y el 2013 a
excepción de qatar y emiratos árabes
unidos- así concluimos esta breve
historia de la revolución egipcia de
2011 en el marco de la primavera árabe
soy andrés suárez jaramillo gracias por
compartir estas historias que las
encuentran en los programas de france 24
punto com
[Música]